pierre bonjour alors l'évacuation de ce
campement par les forces de l'ordre est
elle terminée
alors oui ça monte un vous l'avez dit
c'est au petit matin à 7h plus
précisément que des forces de l'ordre
ont évacué le dernier camp de migrants
du grand est parisien ce sont plusieurs
centaines de personnes qui vivaient est
ici sur les bords du canal saint denis
dans le 19e arrondissement de paris une
évacuation qui fait suite à de
nombreuses autres à ces derniers temps
dans la capitale souvenez-vous à la
semaine dernière ce sont près de 1400
personnes qui ont été évacuées à
aubervilliers aubervilliers une ville
limitrophe de paris situé seulement à
quelques centaines de mètres d'ici donc
des évacuations
de plus non plus de plus en plus
nombreuses à ces derniers temps et
goûter justement à ce sujet le maire du
19e arrondissement de la capitale à
l'opération de mise à l'abri de ce
campement du canal saint denis est un
peu plus loin de la porte de la villette
a été réalisée comme nous le demandions
depuis maintenant plusieurs mois
c'est l'étape numéro deux de ce qui
s'est passé la semaine dernière du côté
de la porte d'aubervilliers et c'est
évidemment un soulagement pour les
personnes qui étaient entassées dans ces
campements et pour les riverains parce
que c'est une situation évidemment très
lourde à gérer pour l'ensemble des
habitants riverains on considère ce
matin que pratiquement 500 personnes ont
été prises en charge
on espère évidemment que on n'aura pas à
revivre de nouvelles situations de ce
type
malheureusement on a quelques raisons
d'être en tout cas si loin kg et du
moins d'être vigilant parce que les
mêmes causes produisant les mêmes effets
on peut craindre que de nouveaux
compense reproduise
tant que les conditions le premier
accueil en france et la gestion des
situations administratives des personnes
présentes sur le territoire resteront
les mêmes il ya malheureusement pas
énormément de raison que les choses ne
se renouvelle pas en tout cas nous
serons vigilants
alors vous le voyez un derrière moi sur
les images de nicolas winckler les
équipes de nettoyage ans de la ville de
paris en
plein travail pour justement nettoyer ce
dernier camp de migrants le disait du
contest parisien partir de maintenant ce
sont des forces de police qui vont être
positionnés ici pour justement empêcher
la construction d'un nouveau camp de
migrants opération donc de démantèlement
de ce camp de migrants ici à paris a
terminé les migrants ont également été a
mis à l'abri dans des foyers à parisien
merci beaucoup pierre sa vie et vernon
pour toutes ces précisions